british police officers have been told
to embrace the label woke what's going
on
well it's good question because what
they're clearly not being told to do is
go out there and fight crime um they're
being given anti-racism training and
they're being told that if they
um think that this anti-racism training
is going to see them being labeled as
woke then they should just embrace that
and go with it i mean clearly nobody
wants the police to be racist and
suddenly i don't want the police to be
going around targeting people because of
their skin color or anything like that
but i think what most of us want the
police to be doing is actually catching
criminals and catching criminals
irrespective of their skin color and
nobody has a problem with the police
really having training in anti-racism
but the question is what what kind of
training they're getting and central to
this training is is they're being told
basically that any racial discrepancies
uh any kind of
where one uh ethnic group is seen to be
kind of out of proportion to another
ethnic group is a problem
but you can't really go about fighting
crime in that way it means you're
fighting crime with one hand tied behind
your back you you're always looking at
skin color and you're left thinking well
you know have we stopped in search too
many black people this week have we
perhaps questioned too many
brown skin colored drivers have we
pulled over too many white people
and you can't you can't release properly
if you've got one mind on skin color
you've got to be looking at who's
committing the crimes not what color
skin they've got
so it seems to me that this does make
policing woke and the problem with it is
not that they need to embrace it it's
that they need to ask themselves why
they're not busy spending their time
catching criminals rather than messing
about with these things looking at
people's skin color
abimbola johnson chairwoman of the
scrutiny panel
what is this that sounds
terrified chairwoman of the scrutiny
panel that will hold forces to account
over the plan expressed disappointment
that officers refused to say whether
policing was institutionally racist as
they launched the initiative johnson who
was appointed after black lives matter
demonstrations in britain in 2020 said
officers should be comfortable with
being called woke
yeah do you know what that's the classic
catch-22 that woke
um tricks people into and particularly
around issues to do with racism so this
big thing like you know are you going to
say that you're institutionally racist
they can't win on that one so i'm not
surprised they didn't answer it because
if they say you know yes yes we are
institutionally racist then it's like oh
my god what are you doing why are you
institutionally racist we better fire
you all we better recruit a whole load
of new police officers send you on a
load more training sessions you're
clearly doing something very wrong but
if they say no we're not institutionally
racist then by definition of the kind of
woke mantras they are racist because
they're not admitting to all their
innate prejudices so i i think if
anybody asked me that question i would
avoid it too because like say it's one
that you just cannot win in the eyes of
these white people it is unfalsifiable
some of the things that get put forward
you think i'm damned if i do i'm damned
if i don't
and
silence is both violence and compliance
so it's it's not even as if i can't
choose to not in a engage in this
discussion
everything every single different
approach that you could have to that and
disappointment in not agreeing to what
you said that you wanted it to be from
the
scrutiny overlord or whatever she's
called
yeah absolutely and it it's like that
classic thing that you used to do when
you were a kid when you tossed a coin
you know heads i win tails you lose they
can't they've they've completely stacked
all the cards in their favor so whatever
arguments are put forward they think
they can win so i mean if you try and
challenge this idea that we've got an
institutionally racist society with
statistics if you say actually look you
know you look at what's going on in
education look at who's getting the best
exam results you know look at who's most
disadvantaged in education for example
or you know look at who's going to
university who's getting jobs and point
out that there aren't all these ethnic
or racial disadvantages that people are
making out then they say oh no you can't
just use statistics you've got to talk
about people's lived experiences uh
you've got to talk about you've got to
look at how black people are actually
experiencing racial inequalities and
racial disadvantages now there might be
some some truth in that you know you you
is i'm not saying it's never worthwhile
to consider people's lived experiences
but the problem is you see when when
some black people come along and
actually they say do you know what no
there isn't all the racism that you're
describing i don't feel as if i'm at a
constant advantage suddenly you find
they're the wrong kind of black person
you know that their lived experience
doesn't count it's only some people's
lived experiences the people who are
saying the right things the people who
are going along with what these woke
scrutiny committees want to hear it's
only their lived experience that
actually counts is it not funny that the
most the the broadest group of people
that seem to be pushing this
aren't part of the racial groups that
they're supposed to be defending that i
mean we saw this in america right that
when the defunder police thing came
around that if you actually surveyed a
lot of black communities that they said
that they wanted more policing because
it was their children that were going to
be injured i had do you know mary
harrington from unheard
yeah so she came on the show and she
told me the story about
um the introduction of the pill
in the 1960s
increased the number of number of uh
single mothers and the dissolving of
chivalry norms around not hitting women
holding the door open being sort of kind
and gentle and a protector and a
provider that these disproportionately
hurt
women from working-class backgrounds but
they were being pushed by middle-class
women where emancipating women from the
tyranny of the patriarchy we don't need
to be have the door held open for us so
that men can stare at our behinds as we
walk through and what you actually look
when you when you see the the stats it
suggests that
some women that were
in societies and social classes that
maybe needed more constrained norms in
order to assist men that perhaps didn't
have the same level of education or role
models in terms of what is and is not
acceptable behavior around women they
were the ones that were
disproportionately affected by this
policy that was being pushed by somebody
that never had any idea about what was
going on on the at the coal face so to
speak and it kind of
seems to me that it's similar with
regards to
policing and policies around that that
a lot of the time the policies that are
being pushed forward aren't being pushed
forward by people that are in the
communities that they're actually
affecting and if you ask them they might
not want what is being promoted
definitely and i think the best example
of that is with all the different views
around trans trans activism um if you
look at most transgender people
certainly most transgender people who i
know
they actually just want to have a quiet
life you know they don't want to be a
political footballer they just want to
you know in the classic the words of the
classic kind of jk rowling tweet they
just want to dress however they want and
be left to get on with living their
lives however they see fit same as
everybody else but the number of people
who it seems to me the people who are
like the most vocal transgender
activists are not actually transgender
themselves they're kind of taking it on
board to act on behalf of this community
on behalf of these other people
in ways that actually a lot of
transgender people don't appreciate and
don't want and they've ended up with
their entire kind of life being
politicized something they've not asked
for and and this is uh
people who are not transgender who've
done this for them um but you know just
going back to what you're saying in
relation to feminism i mean one of the
things that i really object to with
contemporary feminism is the way that it
it constantly
seems to bang on up to women that
they're victims you know that they're
really at a disadvantage and i think
that's what i see a lot in um critical
race theory politics around race as well
nowadays and certainly if i was um black
and and the mother of black kids you
know this idea that that the message
goes out that that you're at an inherent
disadvantage no matter what you do
um you know the odds are stacked against
you the world's a hostile place
everybody's racist society's just out to
get you it's just like what a message to
give to kids whether that's to give to
black kids
gay kids um you know girls
it just seems like the number one thing
of identity politics is telling people
certain groups that they're really at a
big disadvantage in life and and often
like you're saying you know it's not
people who are in those groups
themselves who are doing that it's other
people coming along telling them oh
don't you know everything's going to be
really [ __ ] for you and and i think
that's terrible to tell people that
that's how we raise up the marginalized
we'll raise them up by telling them that
the world is unwinnable what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace